[Music]
Sega the desert is
unforgiving it does not forget
[Music]
from the shores of the danu to the Sands
of Egypt and Arabia the Eastern Roman
Empire
swells they think they have tamed these
lands and count the riches they have
[Music]
plundered they give thanks to their god
with extravagant
tribute but there is another whose
hunger for gold must be
[Music]
Satan this appetite knows no
end
so they hasten to tighten their grip on
the wealth of the
East but as they treat with the demons
to the
north we will
[Music]
strike
and with sword and Spear and blooded may
take back from these imposters but is
rightfully
ours and behold a red horse and power
was given to him that sat there on to
take peace from the
earth Empires
rise Empires fall
all and some are left in
ashes the desert does not
[Music]
forget